nouveau développement dans l' enquête
sur le gang de bagneux d'abord ilan
halimi aurait été tué après avoir vu
peut-être ses ravisseurs c'est du moins
une hypothèque sérieusement envisagée
deuxième élément du jour
l'interpellation d'une adolescente qui
on est servi d'appât le point nos
querelles laurent des bois très agitée
peu coopératif
youssouf fofana ici sous un drap blanc
restera 48 heures de plus en garde à vue
à abidjan des auditions difficiles selon
les enquêteurs
sans remords ni regrets le cerveau du
gang des barbares aurait même menacé les
policiers durant l'interrogatoire son
retour soumis à une procédure
d'extradition ne devrait pas intervenir
avant la semaine prochaine à paris les
gardes à vue se succèdent au 36 quai des
orfèvres
l'enquète avance à grands pas
arrestation importance les policiers
détiennent la jeune fille qui a attiré
ilan halimi dans le piège
une jeune et jolie brune qui avait pour
mission de le séduire
elle n'a que 16 ans elle est d'origine
iranienne
elle vit avec sa mère et sa soeur dans
un pavillon coquet au nord de paris
son petit ami aurait lui aussi fait
partie du gang
elle est venue à la rencontre dylan dans
ce magasin du boulevard voltaire
trois jours plus tard il a rejoint au
parc de sceaux c'est dans cette allée
que les enquêteurs retrouvent la voiture
du jeune homme
la jeune fille a reconnu les faits lors
de sa garde à vue à ce jour quatorze
personnes ont été mises en examen
les enquêteurs recherchent toujours les
hommes de main de youssouf fofana